thank you
[Music]
before we get to the news article what's
everybody's favorite snack in this room
go the pink Quest chips you know I like
the Fritos I like the fruit the cheese
Flaming Hot Fritos man yeah those are
good well we're all out of it we've
eaten all of them we've left all the
Cheetos
well yours what's your favorite style
cheese is nice what Welches Welch's
fruit snacks okay that's always a
HomeTown favorite Colleen for snacks or
beef jerky what do you guys think Joe's
favorite is
what about Steve's just the alcohol none
of it dude yeah I don't think you eat
snacks wow he looks at it with
disgusting what is the number one snack
for all the guests who stopped by mochi
balls probably they're the most unique I
think
these are pretty good too the
crunchyroller things yeah
what do you got these Costco I don't
know but they're good though but
everybody who doesn't know these are the
favorite snacks
[Laughter]
hey give me one too then oh yeah yeah
I'll take one I'll take one oh yeah I
just want to be a part you know they say
put this in the freezer really because
they put in the freezer it says it on
there actually let me put let me put two
in the fridge right now put a couple in
there hey you don't want one Colleen
um
[Laughter]
we'll just throw something else all
right that's good
the composition
go get those snacks if you want to get
down all right
we've talked about this guy before Alex
Jones Big Ben are you tell everybody can
you just show the class who is Alex
Jones to catch people up well you know I
never really watch a show in Fort Worth
which is what he's known for but he's
just like a guy who has a very extreme
some might say
um what's What's the phrase conspiracy
conspiracy theories
and that's all he says
most recent most topical one that he has
been in the news for recently he got
sued I believe right by a bunch of
parents of Sandy Hook right for for
saying that Sandy Hook was a hoax and
why would they sue him because that's
not true
wow you're speaking like a lawyer you
know
um some might say he's profited
from his coverage of the Sandy Hook
stuff how how would he profit through
his show through like ad revenue and all
that stuff right which would justify why
the court has ordered him now off of the
Sandy Hook elementary school massacre uh
lawsuit yes you're right that he claimed
was a hoax has caused our irrefutable
damage to the parents and the families
and everybody who's been trying to
obviously you know just [ __ ] get past
it the fact their child was murdered so
now he has a Connecticut Jury has handed
down the verdict last week ruling that
the Infowars host must pay
965 million dollars
that's like pretty much a billion
dollars just round up how the [ __ ] is he
gonna pay a billion dollars exactly in
Damages to numerous families of victims
of the 2012 mass shooting each plaintiff
received millions of dollars with one
family member receiving more than 80
million dollars wow wait you could say
stuff that is not true and then they
could sue you for a lot of money for it
defamation but it is hard to get
defamation in the court to unless unless
like he said they they showed an ability
for him to fully [ __ ] profit off of
this as well he did because he's got
like things like inforce or his platform
or his show and again this is you know
us being the [ __ ] peon non-lawyer
people that are just watching from the
outside I mean news anchors that we are
um but yeah right like this guy's entire
[ __ ] career over the last few years
and the way that he is able to go viral
in today's age and the the amount of
influence he has the amount of people
right and then imagine all the people
that believe everything it's so crazy
though that people believe that it's
like it's here
yeah he has a huge following that huge
point he said with him like he's he says
crazy [ __ ] yeah
um but his track record I don't know if
it's like 50 50. it's like it's like
really crazy but the stuff that he has
nailed is just as crazy so I think
that's why people continue to believe it
because he will nail some things that
are really crazy but it's not like he's
like 80 accurate it's like maybe 50 or
40. he's just like
84 will be so crazy but but how do you
feel about like freedom of speech and
also that you profit but it's like
argument right oh I think it's a lot of
them were a lot of people about this are
very uh up in arms because sometimes
like I've seen them on different
contexts right where he's like there's a
very popular podcast called flagrant too
and with Andrew Schultz and those guys
and he goes on there and he's just like
a silly goose he's just [ __ ] around
the whole time just like playing into
the character of Alex Jones but like
being very satire of himself in a lot of
ways so that's my only rule
like exposure to him I've never really
seen him on a show unfortunately but I'm
sure on a show he's presenting a very
like news-like Persona and I think
that's probably where they have most of
the damage on him is him talking about
these really crazy theories of Sandy
Hook and him having that context of I'm
reporting the news you know so it's like
I think you could play different hats
and sometimes he might be just like
sometimes when we're talking about this
stuff sometimes we want to [ __ ] around
sometimes we don't sometimes we want to
be serious sometimes we don't and I
think that's where he got caught up in
but so the Court ruled in the favor of
the families
what would how do you guys all feel
about the well well let me let me let me
put it from this perspective for example
um
as a result of Alex Jones claims
families of those killed in the horrific
School accident uh or attack shocked the
world and uh have been the the people
the family have been harassed by fellow
conspiracy theorists for nearly 10 years
now oh my God right holy [ __ ] that's how
long he's been talking about this for
yeah and during during last week's
closing statements in court lawyers
acting on behalf of the families of the
Sandy Hook victim said Jones and his
company Free Speech Systems LLC have
cashed in on his conspiracy theories for
years lawyers said Jones lies about the
shooting boosted traffic to his website
and made him millions of dollars in
Revenue as the victim's family suffered
a decade-long campaign of harassment and
death threats by Jones followers so like
imagine like people hella believe this
guy yeah super influencer so the now
families are getting like called out
they're getting death threats
for like a decade that's really hard to
heal yeah so that means that he made so
much [ __ ] money from your show but
it's the that's what the main argument
is it's it's not that he was saying
something it's that what he said
activated real world consequences where
people went to addresses that he
mentioned they went to and did things he
was mentioning people's address no I
mean like that pizzagate [ __ ] oh yeah
that's like people really went to the
real pizza place trying to expose some
kind of like pedophile ring that didn't
exist but where do you draw the line of
like okay saying this is okay but he
didn't know that people was gonna go but
maybe the people who were harassed they
should be punished for sure because it's
like you can't do that but that that
that's like uh maybe uh think about like
when
Trump was inciting people to go to the
the you know what I'm saying so it's
like
who people were obviously getting mad at
Trump too for like you know getting
people riled up right no I'm just saying
that he didn't did you go dude you just
didn't make the trip but like if it
wasn't for his influence right like
those people who ended up that did go
that got in trouble it's kind of like
they went because they were influenced
by him right yeah so it's kind of like a
similar thing like the people that are
doing the harassing yeah they only are
doing that because they believe in what
Alex is talking about the line of
freedom of speech that I don't know then
is the thing well think about this as
well during the court case Jones
admitted that his claims about Sandy
Hook shooting had been false but refused
to apologize to the families okay a
representative for Jones company
testified that they had made at least
100 million dollars in the past decade
so somebody from his [ __ ] like you
know entire ecosystem testified and said
that so that figure aided the jury in
coming up with a damage structure for
their final decision uh and the third
trial in Texas involving the parents of
another the child Selena Sandy Hook is
set to begin near the end of this year
wow but like I do I do Wonder like if
somebody testifies and says in the last
decade we've made 100 million dollars
how does the jury go all right then you
got to pay 965 million dollars yeah what
what happens if he just doesn't have it
yeah right or that's also like the nine
lifetimes thing right oh right like when
someone's like wait what do you mean
like so he's gonna be in jail for 900
years like in the case there's a random
case someone does live that long or you
know you feel like there should be a cap
so if you made 100 million maybe just
call it well then 100 million or how
much do you have in your bank account
versus just timesing another one another
you just have to pay forever dude yeah
it just means he's always paying a
portion of his earnings forever yeah
which is pretty crazy but yeah it makes
sense that like I think especially with
uh any ruling especially if this if like
higher courts are deciding verdicts
they're gonna go with whatever
societally beneficial and it seems like
if they allowed that to slide the things
that could give birth to in terms of
CopyCat creators like that would just be
completely batshit yeah especially with
a Stranglehold of people with like media
these days too right like anybody can
build audience anywhere depending on you
know the right like tactics of the use
so for someone like
like I think like my parents if they
knew there was a guy like Alex Jones
making content
like five years ten years ago they'd be
like there's no way this guy's gonna be
[ __ ] big you know but now he has a
platform of like millions of people that
are actively inciting his theories you
know so but that's what I'm saying like
so where can you say like okay you can't
put this content out but this is okay
well I think when you're saying like his
his case is very extreme because yeah
there's very there's like cold hard
evidence that this probably wasn't a
[ __ ] uh or maybe when you started
when I say probably or maybe when you
start dropping addresses
that's pretty crazy or also you're
talking about like Free Speech but like
uh in essence the argument is this guy's
free speeches like anybody can say
anything right but if you say stuff and
then it's like causing me harm yeah
like if I'm the families right if I'm
the parents you're saying free things
and now it's like causing my life yeah
okay yeah so it's like is that free
speech yeah I mean like that I think
that's when the lines crossed you can
say whatever you want but where's the
line like what words you put together
and I also think what he's saying too is
like let's say I go hey Nick and I think
you [ __ ] broke my heart dude I'm like
yeah [ __ ] that guy can I leave Nick
beats your ass is it because my
influence on him because of my platform
or does he have any responsibility for
going to to like uh harass the Sandy
Hook parents you know I see what you're
saying but break my heart is so
subjective and personal let's say um
let's say it's like uh you said hey uh
Anthony [ __ ] slapped that kid over
there so Nick's like [ __ ] this one comes
over and whoops my ass
and then later on the kids like no he
didn't
because there's like a There's an actual
truth there's the fact person that's
like wait a minute no there's actual
fact here people should be responsible
for their actions regardless of where
it's stemmed from yeah and also people
should fact check more you know you know
if you're listening to Alex Jones he
already has he already has like a cloud
of like you can't trust [ __ ] anything
yeah I [ __ ] trust anybody
undertones of his home yeah so it's like
it's already in a false pretense of like
you know any anything the regular media
is portraying is false so I don't know I
think it's a slippery slope that's I
think the difference to me is that um
like there's people that have maintained
till this day that the Jewish Holocaust
wasn't real they're saying that that was
a hoax people are saying 911 was an
entire job but they're not actively
campaigning against mobilizing against
the survivors of these things they're
not like creating some kind of like Army
of followers yeah that's what we'll do
you're bidding that you're not actively
doing but you're just telling people to
be enraged about it nobody's going over
to you know no one's doing anything
really but then in this case because it
had real world consequences I think
that's the line just like on Twitch if
you talk [ __ ] about another Creator and
your following goes over there and
harasses their chat you are banned from
twitch
it doesn't matter how big of a Creator
you are you do that [ __ ] that's it but
what if you're right at the time
but I'm saying like what if there's a
case where somebody was right and then
they mobilize a bunch of people and I
think you're okay that's crazy if he was
right I think you're okay but like I
think they would just exonerate him and
they would have the biggest [ __ ] key
to the city dude imagine you're
listening to Joe Rogan and Joe Rogan's
talking about like yo Sandy Hook is
[ __ ] sketch balls
but then okay that's one level right and
then you believe from now on like all
you do is Sandy Hook wasn't real bro
like you that's you but then to the
another level of like we gotta go invest
that's crazy that's the difference the
difference is is what will happen from
you saying it versus you just saying it
yeah you know what I mean because you
could say like loose change documentary
that totally put 911 into question was
into question it wasn't into action you
watched it and the way they phrased
everything was we would like to ask
these questions about why it looked like
a controlled ex like demolition blah
blah like here's all these professionals
that also think the same what do you
think it's the same way it's the same
way reporters have to say allegedly when
there's video clearly of the guy
stabbing something so all we have to say
so all we have to say is a legend it's
legal language it's like you have to be
careful with legal language because if
someone can put them
right now
but it's just that simple if you don't
say it then the news station gets sued
for what allegedly he may have died if
we want to say some wild [ __ ] all we
have to say is
honestly let's go honestly how come
people don't do that more they just
forget you hey Nick allegedly you're a
[ __ ] thanks man I appreciate
that
laughs
thank you